Abby and Matt on their engagement you
guys look so cute here
[Music]
that's Kenzie Scott
she's definitely on my list wetless you
know my celebrity free pass list I
expected someone was a little more
personality that's maybe our lists mean
different things
what would I even say to her
where are you headed
laughs
my life is over my fiance slept with
Kenzie's back hey we just gotta figure
out what the next step is everything's
always been about Matt maybe it's time I
finally do something for myself
I'm gonna sleep at this library for my
life
that's so shallow I love this for you we
need a damn good plan it's Nick viol
what would you even say to him I happen
to be a ninja with words we accept this
Rose that's Daisy it's so funny thanks
but no thanks they'll ninja with those
words there hey for what it's worth I
did think you had a shot thanks
you should go back in there no God no
look at you all smiles we're just
hanging out I have four names left on
this list this has to be surgical check
it out it's Oscar Isaac and his weekly
spin class
you're literally not moving your legs
[Music]
everybody has a fantasy about spending a
night with a celebrity
I'm finding someone to spend the rest of
your life with
that's defensive
you have a fascinating love life Abby